-As the house prepares
for a formal vote to authorize
the impeachment inquiry
into President Trump,
Republicans are comparing their
situation to a horror movie.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Suspenseful theme plays ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
Just step back and remember
that, from day one,
the actual facts
in the Ukraine scandal
have been damning
for the president.
We have the notes from the call.
We know that Trump held up
hundreds of millions of dollars
in military aid
that Congress had specifically
directed to Ukraine
and, while he was
holding up that aid,
Trump asked
the Ukrainian president
to investigate
his political rivals.
It's all right there.
Trump mentions the Bidens,
by name, multiple times.
The only -- the only --
legitimate reason
a president has ever had
for mentioning Joe Biden
on a call with a foreign leader
is when Obama had
to apologize for him.
[ Laughter ]
[as Obama] Uh,
Mr. Prime Minister,
I'm, uh, sorry about Joe.
[ Laughter ]
Just because he could see
London and France
does not mean he, uh...
should've anything
about your underpants.
[ Laughter ]
And, of course, let's not forget
that, during that phone call
with the president of Ukraine,
Trump literally said the words,
"I would like you
to do us a favor."
Remember, during the
Russia investigation,
when everyone was wondering
if there would be a smoking gun,
well, this is the smoking gun.
It turns out the smoking gun was
Donald Trump's mouth
the whole time.
[ Laughter ]
And his brain,
much like a revolver,
is only capable
of holding six words.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
Now, we know -- we know --
We know that one of those
words is "perfect"
because Trump keeps insisting,
every time he speaks,
almost without fail,
that his phone call
with the president of Ukraine
was not just unimpeachable,
but perfect.
He has said it dozens of times,
including multiple times
just in the last week.
-The level of unfairness
for a perfect conversation
with the president of Ukraine.
This was a perfect conversation.
But this was
a perfect conversation.
It's one conversation that I had
with the president of Ukraine
that was perfect.
[ Laughter ]
I had a perfect conversation
with the president of Ukraine.
Perfect. The conversation
has been perfect.
[ Laughter ]
I have a perfect conversation.
Perfect.
The conversation was --
was perfect.
[ Laughter ]
-Stop saying "perfect"!
When you overcompensate
like that,
it only makes you
[laughing] sound guiltier.
[ Laughter ]
Most people, if you accuse them
of robbing a bank would say,
"I didn't do it."
Trump would say --
[as Trump]
It was a perfect transaction.
[ Laughter ]
I filled out the slip;
the teller was polite.
Perfect.
[ Laughter ]
[ Fresh laughter ]
Trump is just a weird,
weird man.
He's like an alien who learned
to mimic human behavior,
[ Laughter ]
but didn't do all the homework.
Like when he was
givin' out Halloween candy
at the White House and,
for some reason,
[ Laughter ]
decided to put some
on top of a kid's head.
[ Fresh laughter ]
What's wrong with you?
Are you -- Is this your first
Halloween on Earth?
[ Laughter ]
[as Trump] On my home planet,
you place the candy
up on the head of the minion,
[ Laughter ]
where it waits.
until all seven moons are
in alignment.
If Trump's gonna do that,
he should have to put candy
on the head
[laughing] of all his minions.
We're joined now by White House
Senior Advisor Stephen Miller.
Is that a Hershey Kiss
on your head?
[ Laughter ]
[as Miller] It is.
The president put it here
and I, for one, am happy
we finally have a leader
with the courage
to put candy on the heads
of the American people.
[ Laughter ]
But Trump's insistence
that the call was perfect
is actually a huge problem
for his fellow Republicans.
Those Republicans are
reportedly dreading having
to actually cast a vote
in the impeachment inquiry,
if it gets to the Senate
because, on one hand,
they know what Trump did
was wrong,
but, on the other hand,
Trump won't admit it was wrong.
So they have no wiggle room.
They're basically parents
sitting in the principal's
office, saying,
"I promise our son won't pull
the fire alarm again,"
while the son is sitting
next to them, saying --
[as Trump] Oh, yeah,
I'm gonna do it again.
[ Laughter ]
And they have to say,
"He's not gonna to do it again.
He's not gonna pull it.
He knows what he did was wrong."
And he's saying --
[as Trump] It wasn't wrong.
It was perfect.
[ Laughter ]
It was super loud
and it was super funny.
[ Laughter ]
And, on top of that,
Republicans are also afraid
of what else might come out
during the impeachment inquiry.
According
to The Washington Post,
Republicans voiced exasperation
at the expectation
that they defend the president
against the troublesome picture
that had been painted,
with neither convincing
arguments from the White House
nor confidence that something
worse will soon be discovered.
One veteran Republican
senator said,
"It feels like a horror movie."
Yeah, every minute
with Donald Trump
feels like a horror movie.
[ Laughter ]
That's why Rudy always looks
like he just closed
the medicine cabinet
and saw the reflection
of the killer behind him.
[ Laughter ]
And, I'm sorry, but you guys
don't get to complain
that you're in a horror movie
[laughing]
when you're the ones
who invited the Babicrook
into the White House.
[ Laughter ]
But Republicans were right
about one thing:
It does keep getting worse
as more information comes out
about the quid pro quo
Trump and his team tried
to orchestrate with Ukraine.
For example, you might remember
that the memo from the call
that was released from the
White House specifically said
it was not a verbatim transcript
of the discussion,
but that didn't stop Trump
from insisting it was, anyway.
-You had stenographers,
you had people
that took it down exactly.
It was a perfect call.
All you have to read what they
wrote down, the stenographers.
They wrote down an exact call.
We had stenographers
on the phone,
takin' it down, word-for-word.
This is an exact,
word-for-word transcript
of the conversation, right?
Taken by very talented
stenographers.
-First of all,
they must've been talented
to make sense of what the
hell you are saying.
[ Laughter ]
In fact, we know --
we know it's hard to transcribe
Trump because, one time,
Trump could not say
the word "origins,"
so the White House literally had
to make up a new word,
spelled "oranges,"
[ Laughter ]
which appeared in an actual
White House transcript
because that's how Trump
kept pronouncing it.
-I hope they now go and take
a look at the oranges,
[ Laughter ]
the oranges of the, uh,
investigation, the beginnings.
The Mueller Report,
I wish, covered
the oranges, how it started.
[ Laughter ]
-Remember when the president
of the United States
couldn't even say the word
[laughs] "origins"?
Like a college freshman
who accidently took too big
of a rip off a bong.
[ Inhaling raspily ]
You know what's a funny word?
[ Laughter ]
Orange-ins.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, it definitely seemed,
at the time,
like the memo of Trump's call
was not, in fact,
a complete transcript
because there were
multiple ellipses throughout
and those were definitely
not pauses
because Donald Trump
does not take pauses.
He just yammers
until he runs out of oxygen
and then inhales like he's
about to go pearl diving.
[ Laughter ]
[ Huffing and puffing ]
[ Fresh laughter ]
This week, we found out
that the transcript
Trump claimed was word-for-word
was not, in fact, word-for-word.
The top Ukraine expert on the
National Security Council,
Lieutenant Colonel
Alexander Vindman,
who listened to the call,
testified on Tuesday
that the notes from the call
had some missing phrases
and that he tried
to correct the transcript.
Now, to be clear, the phrases
do not fundamentally change
lawmakers' understanding
of the call, but nonetheless,
this makes clear that Vindman
is an extremely credible witness
who offered a firsthand account
of critical episodes
in the quid pro quo
and was so troubled
by Trump's July phone call
with Ukraine's president
that he reported his concerns
to his superior.
The behavior was so troubling
that Trump's allies
can't actually defend it,
so, instead,
they're attacking the process
and the witnesses themselves,
like Vindman,
a decorated Iraq War veteran
who received a Purple Heart.
Trump allies in Congress
and the media have suggested
that Vindman might have
an affinity towards Ukraine
because he emigrated from there
when he was three.
-So, he's got a Purple Heart
and he is from the Soviet Union.
He emigrated here
and has an affinity
to the Ukrainian people.
We also know he was born
in the Soviet Union,
emigrated with his family,
young.
He tends to feel simpatico
with the Ukraine.
-Simpatico? What are you,
[ Laughter ]
a right-wing beat poet?
That cat wigged out.
Because he's simpatico,
daddy-o, you dig it?
[ Laughter ]
Republicans can't defend
Trump's corrupt abuses of power
because they are indefensible.
There's nothing they can say.
In fact, they're so at a loss
to defend him that,
even when it comes up
in private,
they quickly move on
to other topics.
Here's how Democratic
Senator Chris Coons explained
his private conversations
with Republicans in the Senate
about impeachment.
-I've worked hard to develop
some meaningful friendships
with my Republican colleagues,
in order to be able to legislate
on a wide range of issues.
We are having no
meaningful conversations
-Hm.
-about what's the path forward
about the president's conduct
with regard to Ukraine.
When I've tried to open
conversations about this,
my friends changed the subject.
-How do you just change
the subject?
Let's talk about impeachment.
"Speaking of peaches,
would you like some fruit?"
[ Laughter ]
I got a bowl fulla --"
-Oranges.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Trump allies
[ Whistling ]
have run out of defenses,
so, now, they're just whining
about the process
and smearing a witness simply
because he was alarmed
by the president's
corrupt behavior.
Republicans
have nothing left to say,
so all they can do is
repeat Trump's lies
and some of them are doing it...
-Word-for-word.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]